quoi mais qu'est ce que c'est que ce
titre mesdames et messieurs bonjour
aujourd'hui au menu nous allons parler
de la terre qui serait plate en deux
phrases vous vous demandez déjà
peut-être pourquoi je parle de ça sur
cette chaîne eh bien ceux qui sont venus
me voir en spectacle le savent déjà
parce que je suis passionné
d'astrophysique d'où le titre de mon
spectacle singularité pause vous êtes
d'ailleurs déjà quinze mille à être venu
voir mon spectacle et je vous remercie
pour les retours de ouf que vous m'avez
fait la tournée continue également avec
de nombreuses villes en belgique en
suisse en france bien sûr toutes les
villes sont sur le site en lien dans la
description mais j'ouvre également une
nouvelle date à paris le 31 décembre
dans ce haut lieu de fou qui s'appelle
la scène musicale la billetterie vient
d'ouvrir
vous faites un des premiers à le savoir
voilà moi je vis seul alors pour que
cette chaîne me ressemble vraiment il
faut que je parle de tous les sujets qui
m'intéressent réellement et c'est le cas
de la terre plate ce phénomène prend de
plus en plus d'ampleur il fallait que
j'en parle ici
loïc génériques
[Musique]
une étude de 2017 dont je vous mets le
lien dans la bio a démontré que 9 % des
français pensent que la terre est plate
et que tout ça fait partie d'un énorme
complot pour nous faire croire qu'elle
est ronde
naïfs que nous sommes la théorie de la
perte c'est donc ça à dire que la terre
est plate comme ça au lieu d'être ronde
comme ceux ci c'est magnifique
comme je suis curieux de tout et que je
considère qu'il faut toujours être
prudent avec ce qu'on croit savoir je me
suis intéressé à tout ça je me suis dit
ok peut-être la terre est plate il faut
que je m'y intéresse et j'ai commencé à
faire des petites recherches sur le
sujet bon alors c'est pas si récent que
ça puisque depuis 1956 aux etats unis la
flat earth society et cherche à
démontrer que la terre est plate
en démontant tous les arguments qui
viendraient prouver qu'elle est ronde et
toujours sur ce même continent aux etats
unis c'est près de 15 millions de
personnes qui se revendique plate east
oui on les appelle comme ça les plaies
[Musique]
alors bien au delà de la platitude
potentiel de la terre les platines
remettent en cause énormément de choses
voici un petit florilège des phrases de
baptiste les platines remettent en cause
par exemple le fait que la terre tourne
sur son axe et que comme par hasard on
ne sentirait pas le mouvement de
quelques centaines de kilomètres heure
comme par hasard le fait que l'on voit
toujours la même face de la lune
comme par hasard le fait également que
dans le ciel la lune et le soleil
paraissent avoir la même taille
comme par hasard oui non pas du tout
c'est une assiette plate l'a
complètement clac reprenant les
arguments des plates east oui que l'on
voit l'horizon plat et non paris alors
que si la terre était arrondies et bien
forcément on verrait ça ferait une
courbe le phénomène de parallaxe des
étoiles donc sans rentrer dans le détail
on devrait voir une différence de
vitesse dans leurs déplacements
or là on a un peu l'impression qu'elles
sont toujours sur le même plan fixe
comme par hasard l'oit lagarde que les
photos de la terre prises depuis
l'espace ont l'air bizarrement
photoshopée tu vois il ya jamais nuage
est trop jolie et c'est très bien rond
comme par hasard qu'au crépuscule les
rayons du soleil devrait parallèle si le
soleil était vraiment à 150 millions de
km de la terre et ils étaient tous dans
la même direction ils devraient tous
arrivés parallèle comme ça un essai
valka que les avions ne coupe jamais par
le sud
pire ils ne passent jamais prêt du sud
et que personne n'a jamais en fait
traverser l'antarctique puisqu'en fait
la terre c'est un disque plat entouré
d'un énorme mur de glace 1
ben ouais c'est pour ça en fait on peut
peut pas lutter les plates east se
revendique d'ailleurs du courant de
pensée des et éthicien la zététique et
une philosophie et non pas une science
d'ailleurs datent du 19e siècle et se
définit comme étant l'art du doute
en gros la connaissance empirique est la
principale source de vérité
évidemment les plates east ont
complètement manipulé la définition de
la zététique ils l'ont ils ont plus que
manipuler long il en sort du lot on peut
violer aussi pour mettre ça dans leur
propre intérêt et finir avec la phrase
suivante de bassila terre halal a pas
l'air ronde c'est qu'elle est plate
parce que nous on a cette impression qu
elle est plate donc c'est qu'elle est
plate et ça il revendique sa part la
zététique mais souvenez vous de mes
anciennes vidéos sur les illusions
au petit comme celle ci ou comme celle
ci on a l'impression qu'elle bouge mais
pourtant elle ne bouge pas donc c'est
pas parce qu'on a l'impression de
quelque chose que ce quelque chose des
vrais
[Musique]
voilà là c'est le moment délicat de la
vidéo parce qu'aujourd'hui je vous le
dis la terre et par ronde
[Musique]
la terre n'est pas ronde je sais ça vous
choque
mais je vais m'expliquer dans cette
vidéo et je vais vous expliquer pourquoi
la terre n'est pas parce que comment
vous dire ça sans que paraître pour un
mec bizarre
la terre n'est pas parfaitement ronde
l epa alban liss complètement je dire il
ya plein de phénomènes
il ya des creux il ya des bosses a été
créée par la gravité par les cataclysmes
par les airs glaciaire donc c'est pas
une boule parfaite mais c'est une boule
la terre c'est une boule voilà elle peut
pas être lisse parfaitement comme comme
cette jolie boule la d'harry potter mais
elle est globalement globalement la trc
une boule quoi dans le sens ferrique du
terme
loïc respect et je respecte la terre
hockey ouais tu juges pas sauf que cette
théorie chelou prend de plus en plus de
place comme si c'était un peu cool
d'être dans le doute et comme si c'était
cool de croire en autre chose et c'est
normal parce que le sentiment
d'appartenance est énorme on a
l'impression de faire partie de quelque
chose de grand de faire partie de ceux
qui savent tu vois c'est tout à fait
normal mais c'est faux après voilà on a
l'impression d'être quelqu'un d'un petit
peu particulier et on a on a envie en
fait d'argumenter pour démontrer que la
terre est plate mais on n'a pas envie
d'écouter les arguments qui contre les
arguments qui était censé contrer
dommage parce que c'est ça le vrai
problème le problème c'est que les
plates east ont réponse à tout ils ont
des arguments surtout au départ et à moi
d'avoir bien creuser le sujet eh bien on
se retrouve un peu séché quand ils
disent quelque chose
ah oui bah ça mais c'est vrai que je
sais pas pourquoi donc voici des contre
arguments que vous pouvez servir aux
platines et qui prouve que la terre est
ronde
1 les fuseaux horaires si la terre était
plate on ne pourrait pas expliquer le
phénomène qui fait qu on voit le soleil
à différents endroits de la terre en
même temps mais pas avec la même
position dans le ciel et en plus à
divers endroits de la terre je dirais
même le phénomène de nuit tel qu'on le
connaît pourrait pas exister comment ça
se fait qu'à un moment donné c'est la
nuit d'un autre côté c'est le jour
comment ça se fait qu'on voit le soleil
se couche et quelque part alors que
d'autres l'ont en haut dans le ciel si
la terre était plate cette vie que moi
comment ça marche les gars mais
avec leurs théories du soleil artificiel
ça ne fonctionne pas pour pour le
prouver c'est très simple il suffirait
que les plagistes se fasse un skype à
divers endroits de la planète en même
temps un endroit où aller se couchent
l'autre se l'est bel outil de dans le
ciel et geste ils feront à skype une
vision il le voit on le voit on le voit
ouais mais aussi ils veulent pas avoir
un point de la gravité la gravité ce
simple argument devrait fermer le débat
complètement si la terre était plate
et donc elle tournait commencé qu'elle
tente ça c'est surtout personne ne remet
en cause d'ailleurs c'est le tour ne
sais pas pourquoi
eh bien on sera tiré vers l'extérieur un
petit peu comme une toupie là si je
faisais tourner très vite l'assiette sur
mon doigt
elia le tomberait donc ce n'est pas le
propos mais si elles tombaient pas et
bien tout serait éjecté sur les côtés
mais tu es de la soupe dans l'assiette
tournée et puis il y en a partout quoi
tu vois donc c'est évident en fait parce
que c'est à cause du centre
gravitationnelle ça ferait ça alors que
nous on tient debout sans est attiré par
les côtés d'un truc qui n'existe pas
puisque ou qu'on soit sur terre on est
sensiblement à la même distance du
centre de la terre d'où la force de
gravité parce que c'est une boule point
numéro 3 pourquoi
l'horizon n'est pas courber c'est un
argument qui est souvent mis en avant et
c'est assez malin de faire ça j'avoue
peut-être à cause de la taille
gigantesque de la planète
j'espère qu'on ne voit pas assez de
surface en même temps pour voir la
courbe de la terre imaginez que vous
preniez un insecte qui qui fait la
moitié de mon oncle ou un quart de mon
ongle en termes de taille
vous le mettez vous le posez sur une
goule une boule qui fait un kilomètre de
diamètre dans son champ de vision il ne
verrait jamais la courbe de ça vous
c'est très simple vous voulez voir la
courbure de la terre vous prenez un
avion qui va très haut dans le ciel à 10
km d'altitude
et là vous aurez une vision assez large
pour voir la courbe de la planète mais
elle est trop grande pour un champ de
vision et des yeux aussi petit un champ
de vision aussi restreint le point 4
revenons sur ce que je disais tout à
l'heure précédemment les rayons du
crépuscule commence acier qui sont pas
parallèles et bien là c'est un simple
effet de perspective
exemple concret vous prenez un plat
tistes ok vous l'emmenez sur des rails
de train vous le posez là au milieu des
rails du train
on attend qu'ils traquent y passe j'ai
pas nissan non mais tu là non c'est un
petit peu mentalist et toi quand même un
bon avant que le train passe voulu poser
la question vous lui demandez si les
deux rails sont bien parallèle il va
vous dire oui parce qu'ils sont
parallèles et vous lui demandez dans ce
cas là pourquoi quand on regarde au loin
les rails ont l'air de se rejoindre en
un seul et même point ils sont toujours
parallèle est bien pour les rayons du
soleil c'est exactement la même chose
comme le soleil est extrêmement loin de
nous forcément quand les rayons arrive
on à cet effet de perspective
il ya un point de fuite qui est le
soleil car le soleil n'est pas proche de
néhou points 5 qui est leur argument
majeur comment ça se fait que si la
terre tourne à 1600 km heure on ne s'en
doute pas cet effet de vitesse alors
comme dirait mon ami max brod reprenons
depuis le début
quand vous prenez un avion qui vole un
transatlantique en moyenne à 1000
kilomètres heure quand vous êtes dans
l'avion est ce que vous sentez la
vitesse non vous pouvez vous balader
dans le cockpit sans problème vous
pouvez les aux toilettes tout se passe
bien ça déjà c'est exactement la même
chose mais pour mieux le comprendre
encore dites vous que parler de
kilomètres heure ça n'a aucun sens il
faut rationaliser sa encore une fois
avec la taille de la planète avec tes
degré de rotation
vous voyez c'est comme 27 n'est-elle
tour on en fait elle tourne en 1600 km
heure ça veut rien dire elle tourne à
0,25 degré par minute
lcl ce taux monte à 2,0 un quart de
degré par minute ça fait 0 0 à 0 4
degrés par seconde
on ne peut pas le sentir bon exemple
concret vous prenez un plat tistes non
après après oui mais juste avant de le
mettre sur les rails
vous le mettez sur un tourniquet si vous
n'avez pas de tour [ __ ] sous la main
vous mettez debout devant vous dans les
mains vous libé t il parce que vous
remplissez jusqu'en haut presque à ras
bord et vous lui demandez de tourner à
la vitesse hallucinante d'un quart de
degré par minute
ok et vous lui dit tu auras le droit
d'arrêter quand la tasse ce sera
renversée parce que là vous serez
tranquille des années du coup c'est
parti pour le point 6 francis avec le
sud et l'antarctique
je vous ai parlé de la problématique
tout à l'heure de comment ça se fait que
personne a traversé l'antarctique
commence à ce qui a jamais deux avions
qui passent près de l'antarctique
tout simplement parce que la terre est
plate et allait entourée d'un mur de
glace et c'est pour ça bon
en fait il ya des expéditions en
antarctique ça a été traversé plein de
fois et même au milieu de l'antarctique
une base avec un drapeau une statue de
lénine
ces récents et alors pour les avions il
suffit d'aller sur un site spécialisé je
vous emmène en lien dans la description
qui traque les avions vous le regardez
quelques minutes ou une heure et vous
allez voir des avions qui omagad passe
près de l'antarctique
c'est juste que les routes commerciales
sont plus simples après on ne font vie -
à l'extrême pôle sud et à l'extrême pôle
nord c'est tout envie plus en fait au
milieu est sûre c'est tellement simple à
vérifier points 7
concernant les étoiles alors oui elles
ont l'air d'être sur le même plan parce
qu'elles sont à des millions de
kilomètres de nous ça c'est tout à fait
normal voilà et si vraiment la terre
était plate
c'est à dire que depuis trois cents
mille ans que l'homme et sur terre on
verrait toujours les mêmes étoiles au
même endroit ça ne bougerait pas y
aurait pas de cycle possible comme celui
qu'on vit alors là encore certains
plagistes disent oui mais en fait c'est
un système très sophistiqué il le change
en fait régulièrement un mets donc ça
veut dire quand même ça fait trois cent
mille ans qu'il y avait déjà des mecs en
fait de l'avoir grid company qui était
au dessus et qui déjà percé d'aidé
d'être ou non mais c'est pas possible
avec des torches dans un drap noir mais
euh ça marche on dit ou pas le doute
m'habite titre point numéro guide
d'ailleurs les trois derniers points
seront rapides
le point numéro 8 c'est pourquoi en fait
pourquoi il y aurait un soi-disant un
dôme pourquoi il y aura un soleil
artificiel pourquoi nous cacherait que
la terre est plate pour nous dire
qu'elle est ronde
je me suis bouffer des heures et des
heures de documentaires propre latif
pour essayer de comprendre
la seule réponse viable enfin viable
plus viable que les autres que j'ai pu
recevoir sur pourquoi on veut nous faire
croire qu'elle est ronde ça a été je
cite pour nous injecter leur vaccin et
nous mettre dans leur école publique
voilà je ne sais pas qui est ce fameux
on oserait me nous sérieusement ce
serait vraiment pour ça point numéro 9
il est très intéressant il s'agit de
marc argent de ses le leader des
platines aux états unis il a déclaré
dans une interview qui est filmé et
j'essaie de trouver des images et de
vous mettre le lien dans la description
il a déclaré
que en fait le journaliste lui posait la
question de caisse qui ferait en fait si
on lui démontrer comme ça que la terre
était ronde et qui pouvait plus le nier
eh bien il a déclaré qu'il continuerait
de le nier qu'il ne reviendrait pas sur
sa position même si on lui prouver même
s'il le constater pourquoi parce que
toute sa vie est basée là-dessus tous en
tous sens business est basé là dessus il
est le fait que la terre soit plate
selon lui donc c'est quand même énorme
cet aveu de mensonge de dire que si on
me prouve qu'elle est ronde
ben je dirais ouais mais pour moi je
dirais qu'elle est plate
le point d'indicé dans le même reportage
dans behind the curve où on voit
également les platines d'essayer de
faire un test pour prouver enfin la face
du monde entier que la terre est plate
le test est très simple et très malins
ils vont envoyer un faisceau lumineux
sur une très longue distance est alors
sur ce sur ce chemin il ya des espèces
de plaques avec un trou et le faisceau
va passer dedans et à la fin comme les
toutous toutes les plaques sont
exactement à la même hauteur avec le
trou à la même hauteur
eh bien le faisceau qui est mis à la
même hauteur au départ on doit le voir
jusqu'au bout si jamais il faut lever le
faisceau ça veut dire qu' il fallait
compenser l'arrondi de la terre tu vois
alors ils font ça et puis j'arrive pas à
voir le faisceau au bout alors le mec au
talkie walkie et fait montre le faisceau
avec les mains pour voir et donc montre
le faisceau et l'autre faisceaux et ben
on le voit qu'à partir de ce moment là
est leur seule réaction c'est de
regarder le truc en faisant torres ting
tings bring this thing
en clair ils ont démontré eux-mêmes que
la terre était ronde selon leur propre
protocole est le seul truc qui nous
attire c'est intéressant et bah oui
parce qu'ils sont ils sont ok blomet ça
c'est quand même une belle preuve c'est
leur propre test qui dit que la terre
est ronde
merci les plates east comme d'habitude
si cette vidéo vous a plus pensé à la
lake qui est pensé à la diffuser aussi
celle ci je pense que ce serait
intéressant que les 9 % de français qui
pensent que la terre est peut-être plate
regarde la vidéo ce serait quand même
poule donc diffusé là n'hésitez pas à
vous abonner si ce n'est pas déjà fait
c'est très important
n'oubliez pas de le faire abonnez vous
ici vous pouvez vous abonner à ma chaîne
ici c'est ma chaîne secondaire là où des
vidéos sortent régulièrement en ce
moment n'hésitez pas allez la voir et à
vous abonner la vidéo ici de la semaine
dernière
l'autre vidéo très intéressante là moi
je vous dis
très bientôt ciao